[Music]
today's session this session is about
continuous deployment what we're going
to do is look at it from three
perspectives there's sort of ten
thousand feet where we got professional
Lori Williams and she's been working
with multiple companies and she's been
running a summit we should talk about so
it's actually across industry on how
they apply these methods and the
problems they have we're also going to
have a talk by Bing by chap Alex and
Bing is the sort of classic continuous
deployment type product where you've got
a service with very little on-prem so
that's like the the 1000-foot
perspective and then finally we have
office which is probably the most
difficult thing to deploy and Jen
Beckman was going to give a talk on now
and since it's sort of three talks on
very similar subject then instead of
taking questions from each of the
speakers what we're going to do is we'll
take no questions during the each
speakers and then right at the end we'll
have all three speakers up and then we
can ask questions from the same thing
because you probably be asking roughly
the same question for me to the same
speakers so it's a lot easier to just
have them all of them and speaking so
first off we have Professor Williams to
talk about challenges and continuous
deployment thanks Brendan thanks all for
coming to this session since you came to
a continuous deployment session you
probably know what it is but I'm gonna
start out just by defining it just in
case and so this is a pipeline and what
with continuous deployment when a
developer makes a change it goes through
a number of automated checks starting
with unit tests could be code review
there could be a number of different
checks that are supposed to be happening
without any human intervention and so it
goes from a developer to actual
customers no human intervention and it
happens in some companies a matter of
minutes like some companies have they
deploy hundreds or even thousands of
times a day and some it's it's less
often and the point is to get feedback
back to the developers as quickly as
possible but from you know a definition
standpoint continuous deployment says no
human intervention related continuous
delivery is similar except there are
some manual checks along the way and so
I kind of you know randomly put some
manual steps in here could be at any
point but continuous delivery says you
know you haven't yet achieved continuous
deployment from another term standpoint
you may hear also DevOps a lot and
DevOps is an organizational structure
where the operations people who do the
deployment collaborate much more closely
with the developers and so I'd say the
you know can do DevOps is an
organizational structure that would go
around or could go around both
continuous deployment and continuous
delivery Brendon mentioned that I've
been running what I call the continuous
deployment summit in Silicon Valley over
the last four years and on this slide
are 17 companies that have participated
in the summit in the four years they
could have participated one two three or
four times if you look at the companies
a lot of them you'll note you'll know
I'm some of them you won't but we
intentionally choose companies for the
summit that cross the spectrum of large
company to small company from companies
that I would say are born we're born
doing continuous delivering continuous
deployment like Facebook Netflix Google
they never did anything but that
although they still have challenges to
companies that you know like as Brendan
mentioned you know there's windows it's
a large monolith their product and being
in the same company again a spectrum and
we have companies like Cisco IBM you
know again and SAS that have large
monolith their products the Uniting
factor of all the companies is that they
all want to use continuous deployment
types of practices to improve their
efficiency to get value to the customers
quicker and to get feedback back to the
developers they all have struggles even
though the ones like I said Facebook
Google Netflix that started that way
they still have struggles they still
want to be more efficient as far as the
years the first year was in Facebook
second year Google third year Netflix
and
Rendon hosted at Microsoft just this
past Monday so I couldn't do my slides
ahead of time because it just happened
and so what I'll be sharing with you are
you know the challenges that the
companies talked about and the
continuous deployment summit it's not
just about challenges though there
actually are some benefits so I'll start
out with the benefits and then spend
most the time on the challenges so the
companies that they use these practices
some of the benefits first of all relate
to the engineers so the engineers are
happier they get feedback quicker they
feel more empowered and you know and and
generally they like working that way
although we'll talk about culture in a
little bit they you know the company
gets a lot of value because they're
continuously sending value out to the
customers giving them new functionality
on a regular cadence they don't have you
know big release stress because the
releases are happening all the time if a
function doesn't make this release it
can make the 1:00 this afternoon and so
you don't have a type of release stress
the companies themselves you know the
attendees said that they feel they have
quality and productivity benefits
although we don't have empirical
evidence of that but that's the way they
felt that the focus on automation
towards getting to you know the
continuous deployment that automation
check you know they view it as a benefit
to focus on automating more and more of
the practices quicker mean time to
repair so if there is a problem the
ability to get a fix to a customer quick
is a benefit so they're you know they
have this deployment pipeline where
they're continuously getting change out
and so if there's a problem they just
follow the normal process and get the
change out to me you know one of the
biggest differences that you can see
with that is back it was 2014 so it was
a while ago there were security problems
found both with jeeps and with Tesla
within two weeks of each other so for
the Jeep when there was a security
problem
Chrysler sent USB sticks out to all the
customers all the car owners 1.4 million
USB sticks went to car owners what do
you think happened to those USB sticks
right how many of them actually were
used how many of them were thrown away
how many of them were repurposed within
that same time frame a couple weeks
later Tesla had a different problem but
a security problem they fixed it over
the air so they have the ability to do
something like that and and any of the
companies that have this continuous
deployment pipeline have the ability to
get fixes out quickly
and then you know in general developers
get feedback so those are the benefits
now we'll talk about the challenges for
companies the first challenge is you
know what do you have what happens when
you have a large change so part of
continuous deployment includes
continuous integration so when a
developer makes a change
they are always integrating they're not
keeping things on their own machine on
the sandbox on a different branch
they're they're actually integrating the
change into the main branch and so what
happens when you have a big change well
generally what is done is it's a feature
toggle is put around that change so that
the developer can continue to integrate
their changes without the customer
experience changing you know and they
can you know keep developing that way so
I have architecture change as any large
feature changes database changes are all
done this way and what this picture is
really showing is you know and this is a
little bit of classic with the database
schema change that what can be happening
is you're using one database and then
when you make a change that has a schema
change then you put a feature flag
around it and potentially what's
happening is now that for testing
purposes you're sending it to both the
paths at the same time the database you
know that both databases are being
populated and then when you feel good
about it then you take the old database
away and that's similar to any kind of
large or large architectural change as
well you can be having potentially
traffic going to the new architecture
you're testing the new architecture but
the users can't see it yet and so it is
a testing strategy where you're testing
and production which we'll talk about
more as well but this is really enabled
by the use of feature toggles and the
way that you direct the traffic another
challenge and a perception is if you're
making all these changes so quickly what
happens to privacy and security and you
know a couple things to say about that
first is organizational the
organizational is really on this slide
so in many organizations those security
people they're in a separate group and
they're not integrated another strategy
is seg sec DevOps where now it's not
just DevOps but the security people are
in there
as part of the team as well tightly
integrated so one from an observational
standpoint the you know you would think
these continuous deployment companies
might be on the leader of the dev sac
ops movement but really not so there's
not a lot of evidence of them having
security integrated as tightly and so if
you take it from a representative
standpoint probably dev psych ops is
more of an idea at this point then
really implemented in a lot of companies
one change that we've seen over the
first over the four years of the summit
is that the you know the security people
are being more integrated that they are
being more partnered with as opposed to
as early in the years it was more like
those security people they just stopped
our releases and now there's more of a
partnership that's taking place so and
that may be representative of companies
as a whole as security as as being more
of a consultant more of a partner and
not just stopping releases so that's an
organizational standpoint I'm the way
that the companies deal with security
and privacy changes are some of them
anyway is if a change has a security or
privacy implication that again they put
a feature toggle around that change and
it is not visible to the public until
the security or privacy people look at
that change and okay it and then they
release the flag so that's the way that
they in general control that
another thing that I would say some of
the more advanced companies including
Bing and and Windows as you'll see do
feature experimentation so feature
experimentation is where the company are
putting out potentially multiple
versions of the same thing or trying a
new feature and trying to get data that
would say whether the customers have
liked they liked the change or not so
this is a Netflix screen and Netflix is
a big company that does feature
experimentation it's possible that if
you and I sat down with our laptops and
pulled up Netflix at this minute our
screens would be different because
they're continuously trying new things
out and they're watching where we hover
how long we stay and all kinds of things
about what we do and then they can keep
a change in or not keep a change so in
the lean startup you know pivot or
persevere they're collecting data
instrument and code collecting data
making decisions sounds good but it's
more complicated and so some of the
complications back in the early days of
the summit we actually wrote a tightrope
release software paper and one of the
additives we put in the paper with every
feature is an experiment and that's kind
of the idealistic view now it's like
well maybe not every feature is an
experiment because there's just the cost
of instrumenting code and collecting all
the data which could be every change it
might have a thousand different metrics
and then the use of like guardrail
guardrail metrics is what Microsoft
calls calls it where if there's
something that you know hits either the
higher low to say some big change has
taken place then you have to get alarmed
to think of what does that change done
and and you know take it out and the
experiment even for companies large like
Google or Netflix that have many many
customers they can't just run it to get
a good enough sample size because we
behave differently in the morning than
we do at night we behave differently on
a Monday than we do on a Sunday and so
they have to have longer periods of time
where they're testing these you know
these features out so in general
experimentation is more complicated than
it was originally thought about so with
all that the experimentation of feature
toggles architecture database changes
have feature toggles security has
feature toggles there's other types of
feature toggles and the company's kind
of do admit that what you know when they
have these experiments if it's a failed
experiment say no don't make that change
they might just take that code and turn
the flag off and leave the code there
and so now it's you know dead code if
you will that's hanging around and so
just all of the the code that is hidden
behind feature toggles can remain there
causing technical death and so that you
know you can have a movement underway
potentially to identify this area of the
code that have these Det this dead code
essentially and try to remove it it can
cause a problem because someone might
see some code there and say I like that
code but because it's behind a feature
toggle they're not sure if they can
depend on that code or not depend upon
that code so in general that the
complexity that's added with all of
these feature toggles the complexity and
technical debt needs to be considered
I'm some radically different types of
testing so as I mentioned earlier unit
testing and is done much more often
which is a good thing but other testing
strategies so testing strategies would
say that you put this code out in
production behind a feature flag and you
test it through the API so like when I
think about what we teach students said
in the university we're not teaching
them about doing something like that now
teaching them about deploy your code and
then test it in in production a lot of
the summer companies say they have to
test in production because they need
that level of scale they need the you
know it to be on production servers to
make sure that it's working properly so
deploy it out there through a dark
launch you know so that users can't see
it and test it that way but then the
next level of testing is as you're
deploying the changes so continuous
deployment companies typically may
dog food a change so it's only visible
to the own employees and then when that
works then deploy it to 0.5% of the
population 1 percent of the population
5% of the population you're watching to
see how it reacts which that's a form of
testing and production you're looking at
the types of changes and defects and you
know pulling back potentially or rolling
a new version now quickly to take care
of a change mobile deployment is is
definitely a challenge so they can they
can even say web you know web
development we got that one but mobile
deployment is harder that this place
doors they do not allow you to
continuously deploy changes and a
company may only be able to make a new
version once a week and so you can't
have the same type of strategy so they
have to be more careful with their
quality for their mobile deployments I'm
also they have to consider that on
mobile devices you may take a version
and you may never take another version
and so there can be you know an infinite
amount of different versions out on the
customers I mean they even talked about
you know TVs that it would be cheaper
like Netflix says it would be cheaper
for us to buy all the TVs back with some
of the versions on them than to maintain
those versions and so there was just
like a change in this year where people
are talking about apps being built with
a much you know much thinner client and
more JavaScript more code that you know
so that what's on the phone or on the
mobile device itself is smaller and
everything else being on a a you know
JavaScript or on the server and the
feature flags being able to be changed
so that you don't actually have to
deploy a new version on the phone or on
the mobile device you just change the
feature flags centrally in order to take
care of some of these concerns and then
the last one is tool investment so there
a lot of focus on tools open-source
tools for you know to control the
deployment pipeline
you know there's chaos monkey tool where
they're you know companies particularly
Netflix are injecting you know
instability into the network to see what
would happen and and the companies share
these types of tools but yet all of the
companies have large IT organizations as
well in order to support continuous
deployment the whole pipeline you know
the automated unit tests automated
static analysis any kind of fuzzing
those are tools I mean it from a
research standpoint the companies are
really looking for good tools and
management of you know false positive
that type of thing so they can put it in
the tool chain and and not need human
intervention so from a research
standpoint there's a lot of need there
oh and then the last one culture shift
culture shift in that now the developers
are the ones that are typically called
when a problem surfaces where before it
used to be like those support people
handle the field problems now it's
usually I integrated something today it
caused a problem I need to deal with it
which means the developers seem to be
much more cognizant of their quality and
putting out high quality products which
is a good thing but on the other hand it
adds another level of stress they didn't
used to have which is not always a good
thing and then just in general that the
new types of development that happens
with continuous deployment it just
causes a huge culture change which not
all of the people say it's you know they
actually say it's it's the toughest
thing of all is the big culture change
because of all of the different things
that the developers have to do they
didn't used to do and they talked about
having like shows where they go from
location to location talking to the
development teams sending someone with a
success story to another location VMware
they talked about going from in this
journey going from multiple branches to
one branch and so they killed the
branches and they had some like ceremony
where they had cupcakes with coffins on
them and you know brought them to all
the locations you know for a ceremony
for killing the branches to make light
hearted of it but but they say the
culture changes are
actually quite hard to summarize lots of
changes you know it's in a way it's like
changes everything
but there's a lot of opportunity and
those changes along with the challenges
[Applause]
so one of the things in the summit is
that most people have very similar
problems because it's it's like
difficult difficult yeah when you have
large software it's just difficult to
have to change it with so many different
people so but I sort of say is having
that range of different types of product
types is quite useful to learn how
effective CD is and how ineffective it
is a certain time so Bing has a
different perspective on this chapter on
it
hello everybody so I'm from being we're
gonna be talking specifically about
being UX so if you've ever gone to being
thank you for your support everything
you see is built on top of the platform
that year that we're gonna discuss a
little bit here today so some of the
Bing poor wide are some of the core some
of the core Bing wide principles live
saw a live site quality is paramount
you know we wear our brand is the
quality right if we have bad quality
people will go elsewhere we're second
place in a difficult race so everything
we do has to be high quality we always
are looking to innovate and produce new
things again it's a it's a competition
right and we need to make sure that
we're keeping pace we need to find
differentiators that draw people toward
us data rules so some of the things that
Lauren was just talking about you're
gonna see echoes of it's really cool
actually yeah
data is what we use we can't use emotion
because if we're automating everything
there's no emotion right so we have to
make sure that we pay attention to the
data we have to believe the data and we
have to use the data and search is an
expensive business it's complicated it's
very expensive to run and so everything
that we can do to improve it to make
things a little bit better a little bit
faster a little bit more automated is
what we go for so here's a higher high
level of the Bing
serving stack it's a multi-tier stack
they are hosted in servers do you
distribute around the world and each
tier is on its own
deployment cadence as well as their own
codebase we handle ingress routing a
throttling and then the UX rendering
tier data Aquarian aggregation and then
the various data based indexes at the
bottom and a vertical along that side is
metrics and monitoring we're talking
today about the UX data presentation
tier we have many hundreds of developers
in this single branch we are seeing an
exponential growth over the last five to
seven years precisely because of the
success we've had with improving agility
and continuous integration and
continuous delivery the UX data and
presentation tier at Bing is roughly is
less than hundred milliseconds at the
95th overall and we render all of the
HTML we handle the API entry points we
handle Cortana handle Yahoo there's
other deals with Yahoo and Apple and so
we we just recover a large space as a
very large model so why did we invest in
agility and this is sort of what I was
just talking about we we need to we need
to stay competitive right it's a
question of survival if we can't keep
pace if we can't differentiate and
innovate faster than our opponent then
we're going to continue to fall by the
wayside people will just abandon us
right so I want to keep my job
I need to support my children so I was
trying to do what we can we need to make
sure that we are able to capture more
market share we run a lot of experiments
and this is another thing Laurie was
talking about the emphasis on
experimentation we run a lot of
experience thousands of them per month
each tier that you saw in the previous
slides is running capable of running
their own experiments so there's a lot
of things going on and the Bing stack
every day so the question then becomes
how do we how can we run more
experiments we need to see dramatic
increase in developer productivity we
need to figure out a way to make sure
that they are further desk getting
stuffed on fingers on the keyboard
making commits
we need a dramatic increase in a number
of developers as well we've only got
five people all working on Bing we're
not gonna see a high pace of innovation
so we need to get more people working on
it and finally we need to see a dramatic
increase in experimentation so we need
to make sure that these features these
experiments that they're doing are
easily done easily created easily
implemented easily experiments all seen
in production and then the data analysis
needs to be simple as well
ok so let's fast forward five years what
was the impact what was the impact of
bajillion specifically the being UX
agility we saw a dramatic increase in
the quality of the live site and this is
something that Laurie was saying as well
it was almost overnight so we were
previously doing once the releases which
really amounted to like every four to
six weeks we wanted to be every four
weeks but what would happen is we would
deploy to the live site there'd be a
bunch of things broken on the live site
we'd spend the next week or two weeks
not fixing them and so we always see
this delay when we switched over to
agility it was really impressive we went
from six or more live cities and it's
per month to less than one on average we
saw that there was an impact on
engineering as well the developers are
much more satisfied they can see more
quickly the result of their work right
it's no longer an asynchronous thing
where they check in something on day one
it goes out on day 30 for us they check
in on something on day one and we
sometimes even get it out on day one but
at the worst we'll get it out on day two
and so they have a very quick feedback
loop our pipeline has also been able to
scale to meet this new demand we've
actually done a lot of optimizations to
continue to support that based on
capacity and resourcing issues that we
had we also see an impact on the
codebase because people are or the
developers now are able to get things
done more quickly we see the much more
smaller code reviews if you're reviewing
less code you're able to do a better job
there's fewer files to look at and fewer
changes in each one you get a much
better overall
you would for a larger changes they're
also shorter and more focused and has
been not least we've empowered everyone
who's Gloria was talking about culture
as well we repower everyone to reject a
code review that doesn't have tests
because the tests are what we live and
die on fragility this is something Lori
was saying over and over it's the test
that make the difference so here's some
of the pre agility metrics this would be
from roughly two thousand and eleven or
twelve we had roughly eighty engineers
in our code base some of the more
interesting things we had five different
development repos one main repo and a
separate release repo so you can imagine
the reverse integrations and the forward
integrations we'd had to do every month
and it would be a huge delay to try to
get that stuff sorted out we were able
to ship once per month we had roughly
three thousand tests eighty percent of
which would pass and they were run ad
hoc so what I've said in the past is we
had some tests some of which run of
those tests that ran some of them passed
and there was just a giant question mark
for everything else we in terms of the
test pass that we able to do remember
I'm talking about the Bing UX we had
less than three browsers it was whatever
the developer had on her machine if they
wanted to do to any browser based
testing at all we handled the Bing web
results and we would see roughly 10
experiments per month now think about
it's like it would it was a
choose-your-own-adventure if you wanted
to do effective experimentation at being
at that time you'd have to say okay I'm
gonna try this experiment where I
changed the link color to purple and if
that one works I think I'm gonna try to
underline it but if that one doesn't
work I think we're gonna try to bold it
and if the bold one doesn't work I think
I'm gonna try to do this and that and
they would have to do all of that coding
ahead of time because we only shipped
once a month they'd have that one shot
they get their code in and then they
could experiment and so they always had
to do much more work than they needed so
that's why we saw so few experiments so
here we are today here we are about when
I broke this deck
it's 46 now we seen tenfold over a
tenfold increase in the number of
developers working our branch and it's
basically because like I said they've
seen a success they've all on-boarded to
our repo and so there's one repo
everyone is working in we see 15-minute
builds we see five minutes start times
and it's it's 10 minutes to test now it
was 20 we met our goal finally we have
one git repo it's a mono repo everyone's
checking into it we deliver code 14
times a week in fact last week it was 17
times we have 46,000 tests now we have
four nines in a test pass and auto
execution we're 14 browsers 34 devices
so you see that we we've abel we've been
able to get things done and and scale
them well so that we are continuing to
improve things looking at the inner and
outer loops that continuous integration
continuous delivery both highly
integrated with the visual studio in
fact my goal is to completely integrate
with Visual Studio so that they have one
screen that they look at all day right
now there's still some variation build
and test deploy staging and we ship
gated by a hundred percent pass rate we
test everything upfront all those 46,000
tests are run at code review time and if
any test fails they don't get checked in
our stage deployments and you were
talking about staging as well we
deployed to a canary environment first
scale unit by skill unit if that passes
then we deliver the rest in parallel so
one of the things that we've learned is
that we just break stuff we broke Visual
Studio for a while they've broken us
multiple times what's nice though is
that our scale actually determines
whether other partners can scale or not
but in doing so it helps to improve them
and then then improving it helps to
improve us so we have a really good
relationship with our engineering
excellence team really good relationship
with the visual studio
team services team and any of the other
partners that we work with we improve
everything that we can my team is not
afraid to jump organizational boundaries
or jump to another repo to make a change
to improve it because we know that that
change improves it for everybody else
and they're fully empowered to do
whatever they need we know also that
scale magnifies improvements and
regressions a great example of that is
we run 70% of our tests on a browser so
the test starts and says start up this
browser waits for the browser to start
up and it runs the test that's any
efficient right if it takes four seconds
to start the browser and we have 46,000
tests and we've wasted minutes of time
so what we've done is we pre-warmed the
browsers we have the browser's already
running and the test grabs the next one
and runs it right so we just find that
we can continue to improve just because
we want to get faster and we play again
we play a lot with others we we have
also got something coming up with dotnet
for dotnet core it's gonna be really
exciting so we decided and we learned
that if you have fewer moving parts
again this is always been saying yeah
fewer moving parts less things can break
you have much better standardization and
things run much more smoothly we have
one environment to monitor that's
production even our test environment is
production just doesn't take traffic and
we say that there's one validation gate
so like I said you are trying to check
in we're gonna run all the tests if any
one of them fails you're not checking in
until you fix it and all of our tests
are co-located meaning that they're
right there so there's the production
code and to test code right next to it
there's no separate repo where we store
tests definitions or test results
everything is strictly defined in our
code base yes so how can we optimize
continuous integration we took every
optimization we possibly could we did
that over and over and over everything
that we could find that would improve
even by a minute our tests pass or build
times is an improvement that it makes
for these 900 developers who see it
every day are able to
faster we have that's the same as it was
sorry my time we also want to optimize
the outer loop so we have metrics that
tell us how much time we're spending in
each part of the outer loop so we know
we can improve we're reusing the
continuous integration mechanics what
you saw the visual studio stuff we're
reusing Visual Studio for the outer loop
as well too to handle the deployments
for us we measure all aspects of
continuous delivery if you can't measure
something you can't decide whether
you're improving it's just bad right so
metrics are super super important
and finally we remove humans it's like I
said automation she said it over and
over automation if you remove the humans
you will immediately improve because now
you're forcing yourself to actually have
operationalized system okay so I think
this is last slide I'm getting this
signal this is it right you implement
the measure and then iterate this is us
over and over this is experimentation we
believe in the experimentation so much
that we actually do it on our own code
all the code that I have all the code
has been written is essentially going to
become obsolete we just assume that's
the fact and we're always looking to see
what the next longest pole is how can we
improve this well this was longer and we
go after it it doesn't matter where it
is we just chase it we every single I'm
sorry yeah
loyalty is a myth I gave this talk
before and people weren't happy with
that it was in a different country but a
simple way of saying that a better way
of saying that maybe is they'll go
wherever it makes sense to go there's no
loyalty to the people on my branch if
they don't like what I'm doing or if
they don't like the system that I built
they'll go elsewhere it's not that hard
so we know that we're successful and we
aim to please those developers so that
they stay in the branch that helps us to
design a system that works and we have
multiple feedback mechanisms as well we
have different ways that the developers
can have their voice be heard we
regularly pull them and
now what is the most important thing to
deal with next and we chase that oddly
enough the most important thing to chase
right now is documentation for us not
even an engineering problem
documentation is is what the developers
are at least pleased with now so we're
making investments in that to improve it
and there's multiple different ways that
we're trying to do it the end thank you
[Applause]
yeah there's no coincidence that sort of
everyone this has been oke no
coordination between chap and lorry but
that the problems are exactly the same
across most of the industry I think it's
quite funny too about documentation and
ireenie that did a talk did his study
and somebody talked about doing software
engineering is very similar to sort of
cooking and writing the software is
basically the actual cooking itself and
documentation is the washing up sir
finally we have office and there's sort
of married difference problems of
officer Jen right I'm Jennifer Beckman
and I am office engineering manager I
actually previously worked in being with
chap and we drove that experimentation
number up to thousands of experiments so
it was lots of fun over there now I've
moved to office I'm in the office
fundamentals group which is responsible
for the build the flighting and
experimentation telemetry security and
performance pieces of office and you'll
see in this talk that we are very far
from being and the the nice agility that
they've driven over there and that's
what I'm excited about doing as I most
recently moved to office in December but
I've been working with office for a
while so when I talk about office you're
you might be wondering well what are you
talking about in terms of office is a
SharePoint or is it the clients I'm
talking about the rich client so Word
Excel and PowerPoint that's the the
group that I work in and that's what
I'll be talking about today
exchange and the other services are a
whole different story they have a
different story around continuous
deployment but I'm really talking about
the apps the apps that are on your
desktop right now what you most recently
made your PowerPoint presentation in
that is what I'm talking about how are
we dealing with continuous deployment
and delivery in office and I'm gonna
rewind us and put us back to 1990 that
was when the first office suite shipped
together Word Excel PowerPoint before
that to releases before that shipped
independently and in 1990 they put them
all together in a suite and sold them
together as office that was 28 years ago
and we have shipped office her versions
of office every two to three years since
then for around 11 different releases
it's a about one release every three
years we would the ship cycle was a
product managers would get together
figure out what features should go in
the product developers develop it and
that we would release it internally to
dog food get feedback bug fixes and then
externally to an audience called mbps or
insiders which are outside of Microsoft
but there are close collaborators they
would give us feedback we would fix it
stabilized and then release it in a
process which we called our TM released
to media CDs discs so that's kind of how
most of Microsoft shipped products over
this time frame and the first version of
Office and 1990 shipped in both windows
and mac mac and windows were two
different product units two different
sets of people two different code bases
shipping independently throughout most
of this time the web version of Windows
our mean of office shipped in 2008 and
the iPhone and Android version shipped
in 2013 and we handle it all the same
way at the time off of the main line
windows branch we'd work the code and
then they
work really hard to make it work on the
platform that was targeted so that's
where our office is coming from that's
where most of the code base was built
its C++ it's a huge code base I'll give
you some numbers later but in 2015 I
pulled up the Microsoft earning report
and it kind of gives an indication of
where office was at the time Windows XP
had just expired its support there was
major declines in the PC business market
and Windows and Office were often sold
together so Windows declined office
declined and that's what happened to
office windows declined we saw the
decline in earnings from office and also
our customers were transitioning to o365
which is our subscription service in
October 2015 that's when we shipped
office 15 office 2016 sorry and this is
when we already knew these things were
happening and this is where we started
to integrate some of the continuous
deployment and delivery practices that
we were just heard about so not too long
ago so let me give you an idea of what
office has been doing and working on
with office 2016 I mentioned before that
each one of the products were shipping
out of a different codebase each
independently forked around by different
teams in office 2016
ever since we shipped in 2015 we've been
working on trying to get all the code
into one codebase it's not entirely true
but we're working on it most recently
Mac was integrated into the windows code
base so Mac windows both shipped from
the same code and that was January of
this year first time that Mac shipped
with Windows in January this year so
it's a really huge accomplishment the
team has been working on it for four
years getting the code together in one
place in terms of shipping the product
like I talked about before you would
bundle all the features
there and say surprise these are all
your features now we're shipping office
12 times a year instead of once every
three years and and that's approximately
every month the features are behind
flags dark they're not turned on for our
users until they're ready and they're
out there exposed percentage-wise so
that we can watch to make sure the
quality is high enough before they get
to everybody hears by the numbers we're
slightly bigger than chapo is looking at
their nose we're we're quite big so we
have four thousand developers we check
in one check in or a check in every
twenty seconds or so we have 1,000
check-ins a day the code base is a half
a billion lines of code not just code
but tests test automation Suites
language proofing is huge tools and
engineering systems is also contributing
a lot to that number there the test
suite runs about 20,000 jobs tens of
thousands of scenarios and hundreds of
thousands of different configurations
every day to get it out to customers so
what is my build slides not working see
that's a it's probably a reflection of a
feature being exposed wrong okay all
right so how does the how do we get
features out to customers it's actually
not a lot different than what I
described before we have we still have
audiences dog food is an internal set of
users within Microsoft Microsoft gets
the product and it goes out to insiders
similar to our MVP audience that we had
before and then goes out to production
so that those mechanics are relatively
the same what's different is that we're
trying to ship everyday we were trying
to ship a main line build every day out
to production its monthly and this
cadence and velocity is a lot faster
than what we were able to do before
also we have feature toggles which is
brand new into office 2016
so having dark code and then present
rolling it out and giving it to our
customers within the build is brand new
and it's something that we've been doing
a lot of in office 2016 just to make
things more complicated
we also split our user base into
different channels so we have our
monthly channel it's mainly consumers
these are people or your mom and dad and
yourself maybe who've bought your PC at
Costco and have office on it you'll get
updates every month through the monthly
consumer channel this the enterprises
are a lot more risk averse so they don't
want to take a the cutting edge stuff
they've never wanted to do that so they
take a build every six months internally
test it and then they deploy that six
month build within within the
organizations for stability reasons we
are doing a lot of investments in the
enterprise in this space I won't talk
about it here too much but giving the
visibility to the enterprises of how
well the build is doing within the
organization is something we've been
doing with Microsoft off 365 it's called
Microsoft 365 if you look it up on the
web it's an interesting twist on
continuous deployment all right so
there's a lot of challenges with doing
continuous deployment I could just
describe with office the codebase itself
is written in C++ and a lot of it is 28
years old so the developers that are
working on office right now a lot of
them are younger than the code itself so
things that we take for granted or Bing
takes for granted for example they're
just not there in the code telemetry
being one of them oftentimes when things
break we're not sure how bad it's broken
because we just don't have the data to
tell us we don't have a fast build and
release process our build takes about
five hours and they
worked really hard to bring that down
and they did a great job doing that the
two get assigned build that's tested it
takes four days and then getting that
build out saturated to all of our
production audiences is about 30 days on
the on the monthly channels test
coverage is another issue with us such
an old codebase the previous
incarnations of our organizations had
test organization oftentimes manual
tests were ran our person sitting there
office would click through the product
it was never codified and so some of the
that tests are just missing and so the
we don't have as much confidence in the
builds sometimes if changes were made in
places that don't have that coverage the
DevOps pieces of continuous deployment
that were talked about is also
challenging in office because as we
build and deploy these releases they are
not in our data centers so it's not a
situation where we have a previous
current and next build that's deployed
we have the hundreds of builds that we
produced and maintain in all of the
different platforms out there sometimes
with shared code across web mobile and
Windows and so as an engineer who's
responsible for DevOps it's really hard
to be able to tell what version of the
code was it and what could be really
going wrong so it's really challenging a
lot of the differences that in
challenges that we have and moving to
continuous deployment and integration
has to do with just historical
organizational culture the technologies
that were used in each one of these
different platforms so web and windows
have different telemetry stacks they
have different way of ingesting and
spitting out telemetry so you can't
necessarily compare the two of them
and so we work through trying to
standardize telemetry trying to
standardize the different metrics so
we'll have often conversations about how
to get to one thing the different
platforms also have just different
philosophies about what it means to
close a build blocking bug what it means
to run unit tests
the Mac team has a great culture around
unit tests they force every build to go
run all the unit tests and will fail
deployment if any one unit test fails
Windows is so big and the unit tests are
so flaky that they don't even want their
unit tests to run so the two different
cultures as it grow grew up over time
just grew up with different ways of
handling situations and we will run into
this almost daily but just people in a
room having different philosophies and
having to work through those issues just
to wrap up we have a lot of market
pressure to continually develop new
functionality within office some of the
cool features around collaboration are
coming and if you don't already have
them right now and it's really fun to be
in office and be able to deliver these
things in this new world where we're
trying to ship faster builds of the
product within there we are also
investing in different ways of
developing office experiences Lori was
talking about other products also having
this challenge so we have this really
old codebase C++ it's really expensive
to develop a new feature in the core C++
environment and then deploy and get it
out to our customers so we're looking at
different ways of developing within
office add-ins is as a way is a way that
we are also tackling this problem
add-ins are a third party way of adding
to office so third parties
even in office 2015 they were able to
add new functionality to office but it
wasn't the first-class way the office
developed and deployed features but we
were looking at it as an avenue to
getting features out there more quickly
as a first party or Microsoft developers
experience of adding to office through
add-ins add-ins are used it's called a
ghave framework if you search on the web
you'll be able to find it and it's
JavaScript based so small packages are
delivered to the client run JavaScript
locally there's a huge effort there to
have that as a next way of adding
features to office and then we're doing
more service-based experiences delivered
to the clients the more obvious one is
the help at the very top there's a
little light bulb and you can ask
question and that's a service based
integration with the client we have
integrations with Bing and when we do
service based integrations it's much
easier because we're able to deploy a
lot faster and go through the services
delivery pipelines instead of dealing
with the big fat clients so we're having
a lot of fun making office optimizing
what we do have finding new ways of
getting features out to customers and
those are some of our continuous
deployment and delivery stories
[Applause]
so um so we now do questions you can
cushion and speak great talks um one of
the questions I had I'm you guys have
heard of the night group disaster with
feature toggles where they had an old
toggle turn on and lost four hundred and
sixty million dollars and forty five
minutes so how do you deal with when
you're doing thousands of experiments
how do you make sure that you know this
feature is running on on this person's
machine like on this server and this
feature is running on that server and
they're not sending in corrupted data or
doing something bad
how do you deal with the different
combinations of feature toggles so my
team owns the feature toggle API for
office and I have to say it's really
hard there is a ton of complexity around
what is being tested in automation and
who has what and dog foods who is a
problem that we do deal with my
experience with Bing when I was in Bing
was that especially with experiments
having a control and a treatment even if
you plan to ship the future you're much
more confident in the fact that it is
the feature that's causing the problem
and then you focus on making the data
faster so all the signals around crashes
especially in being we worked really
hard to get it down to minutes for those
really strong signals of something going
wrong and ideally in office we'll get
there yeah I think I think Lori's
presentation talked a little bit about
it yeah I mean it's complex and you know
you have those Gartrell metrics you know
basically something's wrong shut it off
you know so you try to prevent something
like that but I mean I do think that we
need to acknowledge the level
complexity that is being put into the
code bases which is not something that
we traditionally I've dealt with and you
know there are companies like Facebook
at the summit said they'd you know they
don't they plan that those future
targets will stay there forever they
don't ever plan to take him away so you
know the impact of that type of
development in all of the companies who
use you know prevalently use feature
toggles which is a lot you know it's a
different way to develop we should be
teaching differently because of that
there's we recognize it being that one
exploit it's not even just an experiment
by itself but it's one experiment could
have a side effect on another existing
experiment so one of the final gates to
turning on an experiment in production
is we will rerun all of the existing
tests and force that experiment in
addition to whatever experiments the
tests were actually testing so you get
that coverage they'll know ahead of time
if any tests fail we expect them all the
pass right so they'll know ahead of time
if any tests fail they can look at the
results and decide whether it's a
transient issue or it's a real problem
and so and that's we also do the yeah we
do the flight shutdown so there's you
know a handful of business specific like
critical metrics like revenue that we
will know within a few minutes based on
the control on the treatment and it just
gets shut down like it's an
instantaneous shutdown one of the
fundamental problems in practice is that
a lot of the functionality is never
almost never used so that's not only
Microsoft products but one of the
problems and we have looked into
research to study which functionally
could be taken out I wonder how the
continuous deployment continuous
integration paradigm accommodates this
this idea either any yeah that dead code
is a problem if we're doing a thousands
of experiments per month that include
code yeah I mean we would say
comfortable
maybe 10% or less of those experiments
are successful but we try doesn't mean
that when the flight gets turned off or
the experiment finishes that they go and
clean up the code in fact I've been
doing work like myself to you know
reclaim some of that some of the
addition some of the dead config and to
work with the part of the teams to clean
up there they're related code it's it's
the problem it's a real problem it's a
long-term problem that just adds to our
working set it slows our requests down
slightly and you know death of a
thousand cuts now we're 10 milliseconds
slower now we're 20 milliseconds slower
yeah I think it's an exciting
development to have things you know
updated 100 times in in 100 milliseconds
you know on the other hand you know is
it really the direction to go to make it
faster faster faster faster I mean to me
it looks sometimes it is very
incremental changes and we need a kind
of on the other hand certainly a more
global perspective on the product right
interesting will happen for that
functionality it was never used I've
seen Standish Group statistics on that
same thing you know it's like 60 percent
of the code isn't the features are never
used and so hopefully with the
experimentation and that is discovered
and the mechanism are in place to just
shut it off where before that
functionality was embedded in the
product and so you couldn't easily just
shut it off so you know hopefully that
would be the case and I was mentioned I
guess you said something like 10 percent
of the experiments are successes and
Netflix will say the same thing and I
think that you had a study in was it
office that was 30 percent work that's
being a Bing okay okay so like you know
if there's an acknowledgment that a
large percentage of the features that
are developed are not deemed to be an
improvement and so then they are shut
off which would prevent the features
that are never used it doesn't prevent
the technical debt yes but you may have
been asking a slightly different
question were you are you saying that
it's not always best to chase latency
that you you may have to sacrifice
some of it for feature richness yeah
yeah anyway yeah it's a it's a real
tension that I feel in my team because
my owning the platform I'm ultimately
responsible for the response time of the
server but all the feature teams just
want to get their features out the door
right and so they're coding away and
yeah it's a problem yeah we cannot only
be reactive we need to be proactive to
some extent like this yes so there's
there are you know the flights run at a
low percentage so it doesn't always hit
at our 95th the egregious ones do and we
work with the partner teams to help
improve their latency in those cases
kind of a slightly different angle on
the same question this might be a little
bit naive
but as you're trying to as you're using
metrics and you're rapidly releasing new
features do you end up in like a local
gradient descent where you're kind of
improving whatever metrics you're trying
to improve you're getting a little bit
better a little bit better and you find
that you're sort of in this spot where
you found a product that is optimizing
what your OP want to optimize but you
can't kind of jump out of that minimum
because any particular new feature that
you add is going to make the experience
worse before you can sort of get over
the hump and make it better kind of the
thing that prevents it's kind of what
causes disruptions to be dos so
disruptive because there are totally new
paradigm for whatever it is you're
competing with and it's hard to get out
of that if you're doing sort of an
incremental feature improvement along
the way that might be a naive kind of
way of thinking about the product
development but it's something that I
kind of wonder as I hear your
presentations as much as I think it's
awesome to get like millisecond
deployments on new features it's awesome
but thanks I think there's just two
different paradigms we have to recognize
that they are you're not gonna get a
disruption from incremental experiments
that's why we do rely on new products
coming out that don't necessarily have
to run these experiments because
user base is brand new like teams for
example the new product for that's a
slack competitor they started out
without having any very many customers
they do experiments now but when they
first started out they weren't expected
to do experiments or expectation was to
add a new product to the ecosystem that
grew a user base and then and then
they're expected to optimize the
experience once they have the users to
be able to do that so I do think there's
just there's just different places where
you apply the technologies in there but
it's I think the same technology it's
just used a different way so that's
where dark launches so it's behind a
feature flag they can develop a brand
new disruptive feature for a long period
of time and be deploying and
continuously integrating it but hiding
it completely you know Facebook
definitely talked about that so like
Facebook live video things like that I
mean they did this continuous deployment
continuous deployment and then started
to experiment you know and then
eventually when they were confident
enough released it to all of us so it's
the same technique to use for little
changes and big changes just the answer
I would have given to launch so in
Laura's presentation she talked to
briefly about chaos engineering I was
wondering does being Microsoft Office do
any sorts of these kind of resilience
testing in the field if yes like have
you done anything to kind of minimize
the impact of the failure to those users
yes short answer yes
we we have multiple different layers
like we we do defense in depth right so
we run over all the tests that we can up
front we recognize and that everything's
gonna get tested so there are separate
systems there's one that's continually
fuzzing the live site and looking for
issues there's a pen testing team that
goes and tries to
you know penetrated or defeat one or
more entry points on on Bing and there
is a separate system as well that is
periodically just taking one of our
machines offline and seeing what happens
as a result it's a there's many
different things that we're doing to try
to guarantee for the user that we have a
consistent experience so I'm curious
about how you got from a 90 minute build
down to a 15 minute build was that I
guess this was for the Bing team right
was that primarily by migrating to a
cloud-based build technology or did you
do some optimization elsewhere it was a
combination of both
so there is there is an internal cloud
build system it's called
cloud build figure it should be
descriptive right that's their
documentation actually it's just a phone
bill that does there's a certain amount
of caching as well of previous targets
and they will pull in a cache version of
that has been enabled for dead machine
as well because the definition doesn't
have multiple build servers right but
they will still use the remote cache and
rebuild only the things that we need but
yeah there were major changes in the way
that the code is laid out in our system
and we have been consistently moving
stuff out that the developers don't care
about in fact there's even there's even
a flag for a local build that doesn't
build the test projects so that he can
get it faster build but yeah it's again
like with anything else that I say it's
gonna be defense-in-depth these cloud
build servers there's local stuff we've
done a bunch of optimizations that clean
up you know yeah it's an ongoing process
so is there hope for the five our office
build yes but to be but to be fair but
to be fair model the fat size you're
gonna get it done so far right this is
where a remote build actually would help
them more than it would us like in the
initial days clobb that was great for us
but now that we've minimized it as much
as we can on that machine
the paralyze build service isn't helping
us that much this discussion of the all
the code behind the feature flag made me
wonder about security it seems like
there's a different sort of surface area
now for security text you can change the
value of a flag and now you expose code
that wasn't intend to be running have
you has ever been working in space or
you guys seen any real attacks in that
space I understand what you're saying
and I have not heard of that but I think
it is a real threat you know you just
need to get to that API right somehow
which is how testing and production
often happens they you know they get
into the the API without going through a
user interface so the threat is there I
haven't heard a name of attacks that way
right yeah and so when I talk about
security I talk about you know the
instrumentation and the experimentation
as a way to say this is not right
whatever is happening right now is not
normal and then you might shut something
off to react but it also helps from a
security standpoint yeah the security
starts with making sure only certain
people have the ability to set flags
like none of you are gonna be able to go
home and try to force a specific
experiment or a feature for being or
office it's just not the way it works
like we only allow that to happen within
our own machines it's controlled by IB
now we have a way in from my office
sitting in my office which is inside
Microsoft's Corp net I could force
myself onto an experiment but it's only
enabled for those people I think's so
this shift from no experimentation to
virtually continuous experimentation
that you are going through seems to
suggest to me that you also need a shift
in mindset of of your engineers from an
engineering
centric mindset to a scientists and
treatments that somebody does things
about experiments do you see that in
your employees and you did your
recruitment change accommodate this more
I the culture of experimentation has
definitely changed people thinking about
putting their changes behind the flight
has changed whereas before they would
just push it now they actually
understand let's do this incrementally
and make sure we don't mess up the live
site for everybody else I there is so
much detail on our scorecards that it
would stagger you even faculty even
academia you'd be staggered by how many
metrics we have available on a scorecard
for being so they highlight the the most
the ones with the highest confidence
interval right and they make decisions
based on that to accommodate for people
that think this way to thinking think in
terms of experiments as opposed to the
people I think in terms of code perhaps
I don't think I don't think recruiting
has changed much it's it's learned
experience right look we're hiring for
their technical talent and they learn
flighting on the way I mean that in
Microsoft my understanding was like a
lot of folks who were doing testing the
testing discipline became more oriented
toward data science and actually we had
job title changes and all that sort of
thing happened yeah wasn't I mean didn't
I
I thought we went through a pretty big
transition I can talk to that being on
the experimentation team for being in
office the culture is hard but let's put
the hiring part of aside the culture
change is very difficult the in being
that's the way they live in breathe
engineers they're know when the
experimentation review is they know how
to go there they know how to
intelligently have a conversation about
p-values and what statistics means
in office it's very much further away
one the set of metrics is not as stable
it's not largely recognized across the
organization that those set of metrics
are important and they are ship blocking
or not so we were working through that
with office and just educating both the
IC engineers as well as the managers
about how it works and why it's
important to Tom's point about data
science we have sets of data scientists
with varying different backgrounds
there's testers that were turned into
data scientists I would say that some of
their statistical knowledge is less than
say data scientists that we hired that
has no computer science background but
as a biology major for example and so
there is varying degrees of statistical
ability in that sense hiring wise though
as a developer you you need the skill
set so just being able to code and C++
build be diligent be able to go deep
understand architecture the statistics
part is important but it it isn't what
we would necessarily hire for data
savviness is probably something that we
would look for or ask about and I'm you
know not just developers but also
someone who I'd be called I'd call a
product owner I mean there is a definite
shift there you know this is among the
summit companies where now there is a
hypothesis so you want this function you
know you want this new feature what's
your hypothesis what would change if you
got that and let's specify that as
metrics so that's like a whole different
type of process and sometimes product
owners are technical people but
sometimes they're business oriented but
they you know they have to have this new
mindset to deal with experimentation you
even turn that question around and say
do you need experts in data science why
is could your experimentation platform
be made simple enough that anyone could
understand it without data science
degree
that's what we aim for right like anyone
should be able to do an experiment it
being it's not always the case but more
importantly the data science reminds me
very much
statistics there is no surprise that in
schools you have biostatistics you have
physicals statistics for physics you
have engineering statistics a different
discipline because data depends on how
you collect the data but what
representation you make in the data
whether it's symbolic representation
that there is numeric whether it's any
other representation and then what
questions you are going to ask and that
depends on the domain so yes computer
scientists have role there but they just
have I don't I don't want to put any
number but but they just have a role but
it it really is a a discipline dependent
what what the data data is going to be
collected and what questions will you be
asking a product dependent right the
products are different msn set of data
scientists have a different product than
office does and so you have to be able
to ask the right questions what does it
mean in office in terms of subscription
users and enterprise users versus msn
which is a primarily challenge for a
company like Microsoft that wants to
sell a platform audience nevertheless
you have to what to expect
I think on that point can we thank the
speakers again so thank you very much
your cup